[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des danseurs parti pour un drôle de
voyage à travers les époques
maguy marin questionne la relation aux
autres la relation à soi à l'impulsion
ressenti et donne naissance à beat c'est
vraiment de métaux de base
mais c'est vrai que c'est à partir de là
que pc composer les choses ça veut dire
qu'est ce que je trouve cette unité qui
toutes celles n'est rien -selon la
labilité qui est rajouté de
l'information de la rythmique les choses
prennent un sens c'est plutôt dans ce
sens là qu'il faudrait la voir la
chorégraphe entraîne danseurs et
spectateurs dans une farandole macabre
où ressort une certaine violence et un
questionnement sur la misogynie ou le
traitement des personnes vu comme faible
c'est difficile d'en parler avec la
fleur à la bouche
un rigolo et c'est vrai que ça demande
de notre une certaine hargne pour
condamner comme dan s un peu gagnant de
dire ça mais pour porter cette réflexion
en tout cas fr créé un mouvement pas une
émotion mais c'est la même chose en fait
les mentions c'est un mouvement qui est
un mouvement dans les spectateurs une
rythmique crescendo appuyée par la
musique obsédante de charles ix aubry
une oeuvre intense pour s'interroger sur
le vivre ensemble en société